thank you for coming I'll tell you about
a few new results on understanding
neural networks
so I'm interested in understanding
learning
what properties of the physical world
allow us to learn well and allow us to
learn efficiently so uh and and and in a
sense if you are any good at saying what
good learning means then this kind of
theory or this kind of mathematics
should also translate to understanding
why biological systems learn well they
clearly learn much better than
artificial systems and so this is the
eventual goal I wouldn't talk about it
this talk is focused on understanding
artificial neural networks if you are
interested in this question I I would
contend that there is two key big
questions that we do not know the answer
to the first one is why can we train
neural networks well we like networks
that can do lots of diverse that work
well on lots of diverse data and to
model all this variability in the data
we need to have a lot of parameters
the tasks that we would like to them to
do the labels that we are predicting are
complicated functions of the inputs and
that is why the functions that we that
this the networks parameters are
complicated in particular non-convex uh
by all intents and purposes non-convex
optimization problems which is what
training and neural network amounts to
are hard optimization problems so if you
ask friends they'll tell you that a 10
dimensional non-convex optimization is
intractable it doesn't really make any
sense that we can train these networks
in millions of Dimensions right
this is the kind of question that I was
asking during my PhD and the rough
summary of my work many other people's
work is that the energy landscape of
neural networks is not convex yes but is
somewhat benign so it looks a little bit
like the Grand Canyon no matter where
you are standing there is the river
below you doesn't matter which part of
the river you fall in is the same river
there is crevices and stuff where you
can get stuck but we have figured out
tricks to escape those things so it's
it's it's not trivial but it's not
interactively hard either okay
uh the second question uh uh is uh in
high school everyone told you that if
you have 10 data points you shouldn't be
fitting a polynomial of degree 15 to the
center data points because it can
overfit and it can be very Wiggly in
parts of the domain where you do not
have enough data in deep learning we
love doing this we don't even seem to
get hurt by doing this so something must
be easy about the problem that you are
trying to solve otherwise this wouldn't
work uh
so this is the kind of questions that I
hope to shed light on in this talk but
maybe before we go to the answers it
behooves us to ask why do we care uh if
you ask the practitioners they are not
exactly waiting for answers to these
questions they are doing fine way better
than fine without knowing anything about
this I'll give you two answers two of my
answers
and the first one is simply Pride okay
we have been taught some stuff in
textbooks uh these neural networks
clearly seem to go against those things
at least at the face of it so are the
textbooks wrong should we just burn them
or maybe we did not understand the
textbooks as well as we think
okay
the second thing is perhaps a bit more
important uh I believe that the success
of deep learning is telling us new
things about the nature of data it's a
little bit like building a new
microscope over the last 10 years 30
years depending on how you count we were
trying very hard to build a good
microscope now we have a great one but
the reason we were doing all this was to
look at what is underneath the
microscope and so I would like to
understand what natural data looks like
and the fact that the networks are
working well is just the first step of
that process okay
so over the years I'm not the only
person asking these kinds of questions
many other people have asked these
questions before and in our attempt to
explain the efficacy of these networks
we have attributed a lot of mystery and
peculiarities to them and I'll give you
two examples from my research there's
many others in in other papers here's
one
okay so a few years ago we noticed that
after training uh typical neural
networks end up in regions that are
rather wide in the energy landscape okay
so if you calculate the Hessian which is
the curvature of the loss uh quantity
that tells you how quickly the loss
changes locally you will notice that the
Hessian has a lot of near zero
eigenvalues and that tells you that
about 95 96 percent of the eigen values
are essentially zero that tells you the
loss function no matter which direction
you look at it's quite flat there's also
some positive ones there's also some
negative ones but typically at the end
of training for most networks for most
algorithms you reach regions of this
kind
if you reach regions that are not this
wide then you do not seem to get good
test errors so there is a there is a
utility or there is a merit to reaching
these kinds of regions but a lot of
calculations in statistical physics will
tell you that wide regions are rare in
the energy landscape these are what are
called last deviations phenomena under
certain models uh and so you should
think of it as a little bit like you're
in this gigantic room there are many
solutions to the training set in this
room there is one particular kind of
solution which is this wide region it
doesn't make sense that you are finding
this tiny part which is very rare with
local descent algorithms okay and and
you do so every time you train a network
you'll get a Hessian that looks like
this uh we didn't know why it happens
like this why it is so uh so we chose a
slightly simpler problem we said look uh
the energy landscape has both wide
regions and not wide regions uh let us
try to modify the loss of ffw there is a
training loss G sub gamma is a gaussian
kernel of bandwidth gamma that Smooths
the loss and this smoothing basically
destroys all the regions that are not
wired it keeps the regions that are
wider than gamma and then it makes them
easier to find
these algorithms also work very well so
they are about two to four times faster
than SCD still some of the fastest
methods I know to train neural networks
so you can exploit this specularity but
the point is that you are ending up in
regions like this even if they are
somewhat rare okay
here's the second example we noticed
that the noise in SGD which is which you
can characterize as the covariance
Matrix of the stochastic gradients how
different is the gradient of a One Mini
batch from the full gradient on the
entire data set this is a matrix whose
size is number of Weights times number
of Weights it is quite close to the
official information Matrix which
defines the curvature of the output of a
model roughly speaking okay and we
notice that the noise is very
pathological in most networks and most
data sets out of these millions of
dimensions in the weight space you have
noise in less than 0.5 percent or so
Dimensions all the other dimensions are
basically doing gradient descent
Dynamics and now when a phase assist
looks at this they will call it a
non-equilibrium stochastic process this
stochastic process doesn't have detailed
balance because go taking a trajectory
that goes in one direction is not the
same probability as the trajectory that
comes exactly in the opposite direction
within same two points okay and such
such things are somewhat exotic uh
Markov chains with broken detail balance
even in biology you need some constant
amount of energy that is being added
into the system for the entropy rate to
not be zero and you can get lots of
exotic phenomena for instance we showed
that the most likely locations that you
can find SGD at the end of training are
not even the critical points of the
training loss
okay so before this we were wondering
whether or not you find global Minima in
non-convexiliate landscape this result
says that you don't even find local
Minima or you can happily Converse to
Regions around local okay so with some
it seems a little bit spooky uh you will
also be able to show that the networks
the weights of the network can evolve in
subspaces arbitrarily they don't have to
converse they don't have to stop so long
as the gradient of some function fee is
zero it's not very important at this
point what this function is but this is
peculiarity number two you have a very
pathological noise in the way we are
computing gradients and that gives us a
pretty exotic phenomena even by the
standards of physical systems it's
artificial system okay
and there are many other examples so uh
what I want to convince you of is uh uh
over the years there are many such
versions so for instance uh some people
might say that if you want to understand
neural networks we should really
understand what over parametrization is
because they seem to be they're distinct
from the other machine learning models
we know in this in the fact that they
have so many parameters and I don't know
if you think a little bit like a first
year undergraduate student I have many
parameters I do not have enough
information to constrain all these
parameters so why the heck should they
matter the ones that I do not constrain
over parametization cannot be the only
game in town to explaining why these
networks work because I'm not even
constraining all the other parameters
okay uh if you ask some other people
they'll say oh inductive bias is the
reason why these networks are special
well inductive bias was the reason why
convolutional networks were so
successful in 2014 2013 Transformers are
also exactly as successful if not better
okay so it cannot be that inductive is
again the only theory that explains why
the networks work and you can kind of go
around the room and then lay blame to
gaps in arguments of very many different
attempts to understand this uh what I
want to convince you in this talk is
that we are missing the elephant in the
room the data that we train these
networks on is kind of special and that
is really the secret of all these
peculiarities are that is really the
reason for all these mysterious
properties and if you were to understand
the data a bit better we can explain
them
okay
uh so first I'll tell you a result that
we presented at icml last year uh it's a
paper called does the data induce
capacity control in deep learning
and the focus on the blue line for a
second the Blue Line are the eigenvalues
of principal component analysis of safer
10 images so far 10 has 10 classes 32
cross 32 pixels RGB so three channels so
it's three zero seven two eigenvalues
and what you notice immediately is that
the ratio of the largest eigenvalue
which I have normalized to 1 here and
the smallest one is 10 raised to 8. this
is a gigantically a low dimensional data
set so if you think of a point cloud of
the images this is an ellipse that
subsumes this point cloud and the
longest axis of the ellipse is 10 to the
8 times longer than the smallest axis in
computer vision we've always believed
that inputs typical images lie on low
dimensional manifolds it is not exactly
low dimensional because there is also
this small eigen values but it is
effectively row dimensional about 100
150 dimensions are taking most of the
bulk of the variance of this point cloud
okay if you think a little bit about
this you can also convince yourself why
this is so this is a picture from
plateau's theory of forms so you can
imagine that along the long axis of the
ellipse on one side lie all the pure
cats on the other side lie all the pure
dogs and then the other axis the
longitudinal directions consist of
aberrations so blue sky which doesn't
change very much would be along the
along this small eigenvalue Vector Blue
Dog there is not very many of them in
the world would also lie along the small
econ vectors
we call such a spectrum sloppy uh this
is just a name and here is why we named
it so uh we showed that if the input
data looks like this if the input data
decays very sharply at the beginning and
then is linear on a log scale then
essentially any quantity that you
calculate inside the network be the
Hessian which is the curvature of the
loss we just saw it the feature
information Matrix which is the
curvature of the output we also talked
about it correlations of activations
correlations of jacobians of different
logits basically anything that you can
calculate also has a spectrum that looks
like this it decays very quickly in the
beginning and then slopes down with some
weight Okay the reason why we call this
sloppy is as follows so think of an
eigenvector here with a very small
eigenvalue it is corresponding to a
direction in the weight space where I am
allowed to perturb the weights by seven
eight orders of magnitude before I see
any visible change in the output of the
function okay so this is gigantical
really Stark big redundancy in how the
network uses all its weights this is a
wide residual network with all bells and
whistles about 3 million weights uh but
the uh network is using only about 150
or 200 or so parameters to actually make
the predictions all the others are
decorations of the accuracy your 95
percent accuracy is coming from the head
of the spectrum and then if you want the
remaining five shot you have to dig all
the way deep into the tail the tail is
also very long and it has a very bad
aspect ratio okay
the reason this is important is because
you can imagine that if noise were to
come and change this part of the
spectrum you would see Zero TT
irritation the output of the model is
insensitive to changes that happen in
the in this Subspace and so you cannot
over fit unsus data sets okay nothing
can not neural networks nothing can okay
so we have also noticed that the labels
are highly correlated with the head of
the spectrum and that has some post hog
explanation in the sense that you have
images of cats and you give them label
cat based on the sale and features you
don't give labels based on non Salient
features so they got to be correlated
with the student aspects of the input if
data looks like this if the task looks
like this then nothing can overfit okay
if the orange line or the blue line was
genuinely low dimensional it was
dropping like this then we would all be
solving easy problems and we wouldn't be
very proud of ourselves uh if the blue
line was flat like this then you would
see the curse of dimensionality and then
you couldn't solve those problems okay
so in a sense this Decay is the right
level at which we are allowed to solve
these problems in a computationally
reasonable way and yet solve interesting
enough problems that we care about
okay
uh just a quick uh
picture of the mathematics
we would really like to show that sloppy
inputs so the Blue Line being shaped in
the specular way lead to sloppy fissure
information or sloppy Hessian we can't
quite show this entire sentence as is so
that is why I put a little tilde here we
can show it in parts so we can show that
the trace of the fissure and the trace
of the Hessian is upper bounded by the
trace of the input correlation Matrix
the input correlation Matrix is exactly
whose eigen values I was plotting the
blue line and then there is a bunch of
terms that depend on the weights now
this is a rather simple inequality to
show the way to interpret this is as
follows so imagine that I have a network
where I force the weights to lie within
some L2 ball and so I can uniformly
bound this entire term and I start
taking the size of the I start
increasing the size of the network it
doesn't have to go to Infinity just has
to grow big
this entire right hand side is a
constant
the left hand side grows more and more
terms so at least that tells you that
the eigenvalue is the fissure of the
Hessian have to Decay doesn't tell us
that they have to dig exponentially but
at least they got 20K as one over K or
so right uh
that's just about a trace if you look at
the blocks of the facial information
Matrix the blocks of the fissure Matrix
are the correlations of the jacobians
for weights that correspond to only that
particular layer you don't go across the
layers when you calculate the block uh
we can give a slightly more precise
bound on the entire Spectrum uh so the
eigen values of the block of the fission
Matrix are upper bounded by the eigen
values of the coil of the activations of
the correlations of the activations of
that particular layer again not a very
difficult thing to show a short
calculation but this tells you that if
the activations are sloppy then the
fissure information Matrix also has
eigen values that decay okay so it's
very difficult to go directly from the
inputs all the way to the fissure
because you cannot get very general
bounds on the activations as you go up
the layer for infinitely wide networks
or for kernel machines all of these
things can be done pretty easily you can
show that sloppy inputs gives a sloppy
fissures okay
so there is some insight into
mathematics what I want to tell you next
about is that all the stuff that we've
talked about sloppy inputs and sloppy
fissures doesn't seem to be very
specific to neural networks uh many many
models in nature are sloppy so I've
shown you an example of a particular
systems biology problem this is an
extracellular regulated kindness erk
half this is you can think of it as a
catalyst for the growth of cells pc12
cells in particular and people have
noticed that for instance there is a
protein called EGF epidermal growth
factor if EGF is large then erk shows
spikes if erk shows spikes then the
cells increase in numbers they all
remain the same their function is the
same but they increase in numbers if the
neural growth factor is large if this
protein has a large concentration then
the cells differentiate in their
functionality okay this is just a
particular kind of reaction and those
details are not terribly important at
this point for us here you can think of
this entire system as a couple system of
differential equations the output of
this system is the kinase is the
Catalyst the input to this system or the
parameters of the system are the
concentration of proteins that take play
a role in this are the kinetic rate
constants of all these reactions
whatever you pick we are allowed to
calculate the sensitivity of the output
with respect to perturbations of the
parameters and these are again the eigen
values of the fissure information Matrix
or Jacobian if you want to think about
that
when a systems biologist sees these
kinds of eigen values they are happy
because they'll say ah we of course we
know that the output is insensitive to
many many changes in the parameters
because that way your body can make sure
that functions remain intact even if the
environment changes attainable right so
this makes sense uh in in a post talk
way uh what is uh there is a pretty cool
question that I believe uh we are trying
to solve right now is uh why did this
circuit have to become so uh and the
basic Theory or the basic line of attack
is uh when a system wants to become
resilient to changes of the environment
then it has to become sloppy to preserve
its function otherwise it would be too
sensitive to changes in the environment
okay so systems in nature are sloppy
many many others are a system systems
are sloppy it doesn't have to be a
natural systems an icing model is a
pretty fake model that physicists use to
understand disorder in materials you can
think of it as a bunch of spins
you and your neighbor like to take the
same value in the sense that both of you
point up if the coupling constant
between these spins is positive if the
coupling constant is negative then the
spins are pointing in opposite
directions uh now in in in statistical
physics people have a pretty
sophisticated understanding of why the
facial information Matrix in this case
it would be the sensitivity of the
probability distribution of the spins to
the coupling constants has such sloppy
eigenvalues is because
this is classical constructions where
there are some macroscopic quantities
that emerge because they don't depend in
sensitive ways on all the disorder in
the system and that is why for for
inanimate matter or for these kinds of
systems we know pretty nice way for why
the system has to be sloppy it is it is
it is more of a matter of asking a
different question if you wanted to
understand the magnetization which is
the average value that the spins take
then it is a sloppy model if you wanted
to understand the actual value of the
spins then it is not a sloppy model so
the most important thing to operation
from all this commentary is that
sloppiness is a property of the trained
model but it is also a property of the
question that you're answering with a
trained model it if you want to know the
locations of molecules in this room then
you would have a very complicated model
and it would not show this Simplicity
but if you wanted to have a cat then it
doesn't depend on all the pixels in the
image and then you're talking about
sloppy models okay
uh let me show you one example so on one
application so I'll talk about what are
called pack based bounds pack stands for
probably approximately correct uh
learning theory people will write
inequalities of this kind so they'll say
take a probability distribution queue on
the hypothesis space or on the weight
space if you will uh little e of Q is
the probability that you make a mistake
on a test datum for a hypothesis drawn
from random or from the distribution
queue okay something smaller than one e
hat of Q is the probability that you
make a mistake on the training datum
okay and then they'll say the
probability of a chemistry and the test
is less than the probability of making
mistake on the training set plus some
complexity term and it's not very
important what p is at this point uh but
the way to interpret these kinds of
inequalities is if Q puts its
probability Mass on many many different
hypotheses then you need requisitely
large amounts of samples to distinguish
between all these hypotheses if you put
this on many of them then it cannot
possibly pick one hypothesis with few
samples okay and this is how people will
think of them and in this form it is
about 30 years old maybe more
what has recently been noticed is that
when we plug in numbers into these
inequalities things don't quite work so
a typical neural network will have
basically zero training error because
the interpolating their data and so this
term is zero that test error let's say
it is five percent so this would be 0.05
but the complexity term is much larger
than one it will usually be about 100
even for mnist and so you don't really
need a theory or certainly a theorem to
say that the probability of making a
mistake is less than 100. is obvious
right and so this is why people have
been very anxious about this and they
call such bounds vacuous they are
vacuous not because we did anything
wrong while deriving this equation this
inequality but we don't know is because
neural networks have a large number of
parameters that is why this term is very
large okay what we showed in this paper
is that we can give an analytical
non-vaculous bound on the generalizing
error of General neural networks simply
by the by an assumption that says that
the inputs are sloppy if the inputs are
sloppy the Hessian is sloppy if the
Hessian is sloppy then you can get a
non-vaculous bound on the generation
it's not tight it's 0.38 whereas a
typical mnist network will have this
kind of a test error which is called a
stochastic test error of let's say two
percent three percent or so and in the
paper you can also develop some
numerical techniques to get basically
pretty tight inequalities on the
generation data but the point of the
entire argument is that you don't need
new Theory to understand deep networks
the existing Theory works just fine you
just drop light in the right way and
appreciate the fact that you're not
fitting arbitrary data you are fitting
data with very specific patterns very
specific learnable patterns okay you're
not fitting a hash function yeah so it
principle if I chose a better prior will
I be able to make the right hand side
much smaller yeah that's called transfer
learning
cool so here is one take-home message
from this calculation uh let us ask
ourselves there are many many weights in
the network how many are really
constrained
so they can plug out a quantity which is
roughly speaking the elbow of this
particular eigen spectrum that looks as
follows the number of eigen values of
the Hessian that are larger than Epsilon
is not important it is the scale of the
prior uh the denominator is two times
the number of samples minus one okay and
now this is quite beautiful so it tells
you that if I give you an infinite
number of samples then the network
actually is all its parameters all the
parameters are necessary to make
predictions on this infinite amount of
data but if I don't give you enough
samples
then because of the shape of the eigen
spectrum you're not using all the
degrees of freedom available to you you
do not have any information to constrain
all those degrees of freedom typically
in practice only about half a percent
not 50 percent half a percent of the
number of Weights are actually
constrained okay so when someone says I
fit a network with 1 million weights
they're really fitting a model with
about 5000 degrees of freedom and it
shouldn't be a surprise at that point
that we can get good test error the
networks are secretly small we just lie
about them to everyone
uh so here is a cartoon uh uh of this
entire business uh if you think of the
manifold of functions that are expressed
or that are expressed on this data by
the network
the learning typically happens in the
stiff part of the eigen spectrum if you
tackle the Fischer at initialization the
weights predominantly move in the stiff
Subspace
they don't move in the sloppy Subspace
for two reasons one is because these are
optimization problems that are low
dimensional yes but they are incredibly
badly conditioned so even if you had
take a quadratic with an aspect ratio of
10 raised to 6 you are not going to be
able to minimize that very easily right
but it doesn't matter because the
sloppied exam Freedom do not affect your
predictions much you're already getting
the 95 accuracy and the remaining five
is is coming from the sloppy Parts okay
so you find a learning a response to you
initializing somewhere in the interior
of such a manifold and then fitting the
long sides of this and we call such
manifolds hyper ribbons they're very
long in some directions and then there
are many many directions where the
ribbon is very thin it's just like the
ribbon that you use in in everyday life
okay so over the last year or so we've
been basically making this picture more
and more rigorous and this is the
subject of two papers uh the first one
will be presented at icml in a couple of
months and the second one we just put
out an archive uh last week or so
uh here is how I will explain that so I
would like to understand the space of
probability distributions that are
expressed or parameterized by the
network when it learns okay this is an
infinite dimensional object so P of Y
given X Y is an output X is an input W
are the weights is a function of X I can
plug in any X into this that I want I
get one number right it's not very easy
to understand such an object one because
it's a big function and two because the
likelihood is a complicated function of
the weights that is really the grief of
the entire business uh we do a pretty
cheap trick to get around this it's a
little bit like someone told you to take
a functional analysis class you did not
take it so you take the function you
measure it at a fixed finite number of
points and then now you pretend that you
have a vector and forget that you are
dealing with a function okay in our case
the the points at which we want to
measure the likelihood are pretty
naturally selected these are simply the
training samples
so if you think of imagenet image net
has one million samples so n is 1
million for each of these samples you
are predicting 1000 numbers 1000
probabilities for each of the Thousand
classes so you have 1 million times 1000
which is one billion dimensional Vector
that is a representation of the model
that you have learned doesn't matter
what architecture you have doesn't
matter how you train this model so long
as two networks have this exact same
vector they are the same models at least
as evidenced by the samples in your
trainee dataset you could have other
samples where the two functions differ
and you wouldn't know about it in this
business okay uh so here is what we will
try to do uh in this space let's say
that you have a billion dimensional
space it's not a vector space but it's a
product manifold of uh Pro of spheres uh
of thousand dimensional spheres on which
the probabilities lie and one million
product of such spheres on this manifold
two points are kind of special the first
one is what we like to call the truth uh
it is the one hot probabilities of all
the samples which is the solution of the
training set this is what we want to fit
at the end of the day at the beginning
people like to initialize their networks
so that the network predicts one over
thousand one over thousand for every
class for every image right that is what
we call ignorance so the name of the
game when you train a network is uh you
begin training at this point called
ignorance you end training at this point
called Truth and then you are now doomed
to live in this billion dimensions and
the question is how you get there okay
uh this is a legitimate probability
distribution so we can Define distances
between two points uh if you have two
distributions p u and PV uh we like to
use what is called the butter distance
the better side distance if you haven't
seen it before it is uh for the purposes
of this calculation you can just think
of symmetrical Divergence uh the the
reason to use this is as follows so in
these Dimensions anything that you use
to measure distances between points Goes
to Hell pretty quickly it saturates so
if you take the hellinger distance in
these Dimensions it will always saturate
ah so you have to use things that are
not metrics the potassium distance or
the symmetrical Divergence is not a
metric it's a distance it's positive but
not symmetric uh the KL is not symmetric
but uh it it doesn't satisfy the
triangle inequality and because of that
you can get confused when you interpret
these kinds of calculations because
triangle equality is not valid uh but we
figured out ways to work around that so
here is what we are going to do uh I'm
going to train hundreds of thousands of
models in this space and then project
them down into lower Dimension spaces to
understand how the training process
behaves uh conceptually it's a lot like
doing PCA principal component analysis
we use something called as
multi-dimensional scaling slightly more
old-fashioned uh but this is a same
calculations PCA essentially PCF
preserves euclidean distances between
points MDS preserves uh your favorite
distance in this case the battery
distance between points okay now another
thing that is pretty cool and Technical
about this is that typically MDS is very
popular in the bioinformatics literature
where they'll use it to calculate the
distances between sequences of genes and
stuff like this and after you do this
embedding PCA eigenvalues are always
positive we all know that MDS eigen
values need not always be positive they
can also be some negative eigen values
so you are embedding into minkowski
spaces with imaginary coordinates and
bioinformatics people typically like to
throw away such imaginary coordinates we
believe that there is meaning to them
and so I'll show you what exactly is
this meaning but here is the setup we
take many many networks train them
calculate all these big vectors project
them down into lower Dimensions faces
and they will see what they do
okay so here's a picture every point is
one neural network here okay uh there is
about there's six different
architectures fully connected networks
cnns Transformers smallest Nets and
lastness Nets they all begin training at
essentially the same point up to
statistical fluctuations called
ignorance P0 is that point
they all end at the truth you don't see
the truth in this plot it is off the
edge for reasons I'll tell you later uh
and what I've done is I took about uh
these six architectures trained with SGD
with sdd with Nestor acceleration with
Adam uh different batch sizes different
learning rates with weight Decay without
rate Decay with augmentation without
augmentation about 2300 different
configurations of networks about 150 000
different points that are checkpointed
along the trajectories of these trade
2300 configurations okay
and when you plot the first three
dimensions of this embedding what you
notice is that this is CIFA 10 so the
space in which these points leave this
probability Distributors live is 50 000
samples times 10 outputs so half a
million Dimensions okay
in this half a million Dimensions the
top three dimensions capture about 76
percent of the variance
this is telling you that in spite of the
huge diversity in what these networks
are they live in what is basically a
three four dimensional manifold I can
write you down a description of each of
these points in three four coordinates
and it would be a faithful description I
wouldn't be cheating in the sense that
pairwise distances would be preserved up
to this much okay so this is the
intrinsically lower dimensionality of
the optimization problem we are solving
the networks themselves have huge
numbers of slit in this case has about
40 million weights and many others have
comparable ones in spite of that it is a
three four dimensional problem okay so a
large model and a small model they don't
learn different things they'll not only
learn the same thing at the end when
they fit the data but they also learn it
in the same way we can calculate
distances within trajectories uh you in
the original space and we can show that
the two networks large residence
smallest net they travel along the same
manifold each other the larger one is a
bit faster
so when people say that large networks
work well all that they're really saying
is that the small Network I did not
train it well enough if I had trained it
perhaps it would work as well
distillation pruning are all evidence of
such a statement right
all these networks have the same
manifold that is also quite surprising
not only is it three-dimensional but
they also live train the same way and
they're all rather inefficient so we can
also cut the judasic in this space
because this space is a product of
spheres uh and that would be in some
sense the shortest path to take between
the ignorance and Truth these networks
don't take that path they all take a
slightly different path and somehow the
same one okay
these points that you see outside the
manifold we know who to blame for these
points it is Adam typically when you
train networks with Adam you will see
huge swings in the probabilities that
are predicted for each of these images
but the cool thing here is that these
points uh if you were just to train them
further you would rate zero error so all
the networks in this entire experiment
have zero training error barring like a
couple of dozen so these points are
aberrations of the training process but
they are not aberrant Solutions
you just train them further they will
reach the correct solution okay this is
just the diffuseness of the manifold so
the training process explores a very low
dimensional manifold in spite of this
huge dimensionality yes
one by hand they are just to guide your
eye each so there are different
algorithms so each of the colored points
is one architecture and within that
there are three training methods
different variations of hyper parameters
different brain digitalizations and so
you can draw trajectory you can connect
the points of the trajectory if you want
to look at it that way
cool so uh uh now let us project the
same manifold in the top two Dimensions
so this is pc1 and PC2 and what I want
you to think about is is that the second
eigenvalue uh in this particular
experiment of multi-dimensional scaling
is negative so this is a mean cast space
where this is a complex coordinate and
this is a real valued coordinate so
distances in this space they go as Delta
x square minus Delta y Square because Y
is imaginary okay
P star is the point where everyone is
headed you can imagine that there is a
light cone that comes out of P star
it is a light cone the sides of which
are points that have zero distances
between them that is what it means for
Delta x squared minus Delta y Square to
be 0 if the eigen values were all equal
so these Blue Points in this case are
all networks with zero error we know
that the error 0 is released along
before the loss becomes small and so all
these different networks they try to
fall on the same light cone uh of course
because that is the one of P star and
they have essentially zero distances to
P star but tiny tiny different distances
so the crosstalk velocity is never zero
but it's very very small and a tiny bit
different from each of these networks
and the visualization method is plucking
out this tiny differences and this is
very spooky so you have 500 000
dimensions and these probabilities are
different in tiny tiny ways so you take
one image and one network predicts point
seven and point one the other one per
6.65 and 0.12 uh the visualization
method is showing you the difference I'm
plucking out signal from these large
spaces somehow
and this is I think a very mysterious
why it happens like this we have some
hunches based on the analysis of the
icing model we can talk about it later
but it's it's a way to understand the
geometry yes in these high Dimensions
but also understand anomalies in this
High dimensions
okay this is how the test manifold looks
like uh the manifold has basically the
same shape but then there is larger
differences in trajectories of different
architectures okay in this case you can
actually see the truth in the previous
plot you couldn't see the truth on the
same 3D plot here this is the truth and
if you think a little bit uh about what
is happening all these networks they
should be close to the test truth right
fully connected networks have 40 error
so they should be far away from the test
truth and then chord mixers or large
resonates have smaller errors so it will
a little closer to the tester so you can
think of the truth as the bullseye that
you're trying to hit and bad models are
far away from the bull size good models
are clusterables and you would imagine
that there's a big circle in which the
bad models are spread around because
they cannot get any closer that's not
really the case the fully connected
networks are all together so they are
all making the same mistakes they are
just bad all of them the con mixers are
all getting the same things correct
they're all good in the same way so this
very classical bias variance picture
trade-off that we imagine uh the bias
being this isotropic thing is not really
true uh this is a very clear evidence of
this the manifold here is a tiny bit
higher dimensional in this case it is
about 63 percent in the top three
dimensions but the structure is
basically the same we know that these
branches come from let's augmentation
versus without augmentation but there is
very little differences
okay
same thing happens on image net we did
not train as many models in this case
only three architectures but the
manifold is again low dimensional uh and
basically all conclusions that you we
talked about are consistent
Okay so
in this space of a survey we usually
work we've been doing this for a good
year and a half now we draw these
pictures we form hypotheses and then do
all the analysis in the original High
dimensional space so that we don't get
fooled by the pictures because
interpreting spaces is very hard we have
spent lots of months trying to do it uh
yeah so from this lower dimensional
picture it seems like the transformer is
doing
in Boston uh no so uh in this case there
is no negative eigenvalue so euclidean
distance between the truth and the
Transformer the end point of the vit
trajectory is actually how far the test
error would be in this case so I think
if you're looking at the test error uh
These are 3D plots put on 2D paper uh
it's not that easy to see say where this
point is I don't remember
okay so what we have developed is ways
to analyze trajectories in these spaces
and it's a little bit technical because
different networks train at very
different speeds so we have to Define
some unique notion of time for all these
networks and the way we do that is we
project all the trajectives on the
geodesic and then we imagine a constant
velocity particle that travels along the
Jurassic and assign the time of the
constant velocity particle to each of
the networks so rest net might make much
faster progress towards the truth after
50 bucks than a small fully connected
Network and then the rest net will have
a larger value of progress after 50
bucks okay and so we can draw this
dendragons I don't expect you to read
this but what I want to show you is
these are dendrograms of trajectories of
different configurations I just focused
on this one these are our fully
connected networks trained with
different optimization algorithms and
you notice that when I clustered my
dendogram like this all the
architectures lit up together so
architectures is is the predominant
thing that distinguishes trajectories in
these spaces within each cloud of
architectures the optimization
algorithms cluster themselves into
separate clusters okay but basically
different architectures is what
determines the differences in the
Learned models training hyper parameters
of training or hyper parameters
regularization basically do not matter
yeah
I would imagine the distance from the
geodesic
YouTube so you say your definition of
time here depends on like you project
the trajectory of the model on the Judas
yeah on by by just the great circle
distance so so the distance from the
Judas of course will contribute to
so what that is from the geodesic
doesn't contribute to the time it uh but
the uh if the geodesic is imagine the
Jurassic a straight line it is a
straight line and then the trajectories
can go in different directions so if you
are kind of moving orthogonal into the
Jurassic then you will not make progress
that is that yeah I guess yeah before
you show this
architecture the trajectory like
essentially the trajectory is dependent
architecture so this is kind of
another manifestation of that fact or
there's more information no that this is
exactly the same data I'm not showing
you new data I just put analyze the
trajectives a bit differently
so
um the way trajectory is different from
the geodesic you showed us earlier
depends strongly on the architecture
uh no right so all the trajectories are
quite similar uh to each other and they
are all different from the geodesic
there are differences in how similar so
for instance all cnns are a bit closer
to the geodesic and we don't know why
really uh but in this plot we treat the
geodesic as just one other trajectory
and then this little black line that you
don't really see very well is actually
the geodesic it is far from everyone a
better way to see this is this picture
where I did MDS for the probability
distribute probability models before now
I am doing MDS for trajectories we have
ways to calculate distances between
trajectories right so we can again
create a pairwise distance Matrix do MDS
for that pairwise distance Matrix and
every point now is one trajectory and
you see that the geodesic is far away
from everyone but the cool thing again
is that all the architectures are close
by
okay and in this case for instance this
would be augmentation or this would be
no augmentation so that it gets
different clusters
cool here is a slightly different
experiment of the same kind the red line
here are modest trained on the full
image net okay
and the green line for instance is a
model trained only on all the categories
in the vertebrate phylum this is a
subset of imagenet and you can just
train a different model we do some
tricks of like how to plot in the same
space these models turn on different
tasks as we can talk about it later but
the surprising thing here is that
trajectories of models trained on
different subsets of image net still lie
in a three four dimensional space so in
the top three dimensions we explained
stress in this case is about 88 percent
so this tells you that not only is the
manifold of networks trained on the same
task low dimensional the different tasks
themselves the end points of these
trajectories are proxies where they want
the task is are them the tasks
themselves are low dimensional the
reason we are good at doing fine tuning
or transfer learning or military
learning or meta learning is because we
are solving this three four-dimensional
problem
secretly okay we can also do this very
cute trick where this is the ontology of
the classes in wordnet these are the
categories of imagenet you can take the
distances between trajectories obtained
from this analysis and then reconstruct
the ontology
the visual classification task has a
priori nothing to do with the ontology
that was created from language uh and
but they seem to be consistent with each
other and this is very cool because it
tells you that there is some shared
structure among tasks that goes beyond
the modality and Beyond this very
abstract concept of this product
manifold of probabilities
you can also do in in this paper in the
icml paper we showed a lot of things
related to this for instance meta
learning or episodic meta learning and
supervised learning learn the same thing
episodic meta learning is just
horrendously inefficient in how it gets
to the truth so we should there is no
need to do meta learning you can just
happily do supervised learning and this
is indeed what many people have started
doing since we started saying it a few
years ago we also showed that
self-supervised learning and supervised
learning learn the same thing
self-supervised learning doesn't go all
the way to the truth it stops Midway
because we don't really know where the
truth is we don't know the true labels
right and you can do all kinds of
analysis by this the the uh the way I
would correct summarize these pictures
is that the manifold of probability
distributions is looking like a hyper
ribbon but the different tasks that we
are interested in solving they also
project to the same parts of a hyper
ribbon and this is why you do not need
to change your model very much when you
go from one task to the other task all
you need to do is modify either model in
the sloppy Dimensions the sloppy
dimensions are the one that are actually
helping you transfer the model and this
you can make precise pretty easily
okay uh I won't worry about this result
uh I can tell you later but let me
conclude uh with so as I said the
success of deep learning is telling us
new things about data
and we have really like attributed
terribly many uh mysterious properties
networks
over the years this could be data that
explains it
the second one is a tiny bit more
philosophical so it is very surprising
why there is so much structure in the
data and if you think a little bit like
a physicist
there is matter there is molecules in
the inside the table they give the table
certain properties like stress strain
and why these properties arise is
definitely a question of physics
what function we attribute to objects
the fact that images have objects rooms
have chairs such as some function is of
our are doing so the semantics that we
attribute to data is really our choice
we don't go around counting the leaves
on a tree we don't go around giving
labels to cats that depend on the number
of hair they have right so we created
these learning problems they are easy
because you want to identify this bunch
of molecules in the next image as being
the same cat and it shouldn't be so
surprising that we can learn the same
structure in a division Network the
problem is easy to begin with okay so in
in in in a very vague sense I would say
that typical problems are learnable and
what is not learnable you don't do
and take questions
[Applause]
for a fascinating task and we already
had questions from the audience and
we're running a little bit late I don't
know if there are questions online
okay so maybe we have time for one very
quick question
yes so
so you constructed this low dimensional
embedding and then uh use that as an
argument that the tasks are easy because
they're low dimensionally embeddable
so I feel that um there might be some
some element here that I'm I'm missing
um
couldn't it look different in a
different embedding like like could it
be that
uh
a less successful embedding would give
us
uh
not the same narrative just just how
does that work yeah so I think that
there is really two parts to that
question the argument that the tasks are
somehow easy uh is uh strictly speaking
a little bit of a speculation at this
point it doesn't follow from these
results so that's just right after but
the second part which is this embedding
gives us the low Dimension structure
would some other embedding not give it
yes you can create embeddings that
wouldn't give you this low Dimension
structure but it is a little bit of a
question of
uh analysis or sufficiency right there
is structure in this high dimension
space this method plucks out the
structure if some other method doesn't
then that's the failure of the other
method uh so we are not married to but
as a resistance they are not married to
the specific way of doing things
but it is it is true that there is this
structure
all right well let's thank you once
again and speaker and see you next
Friday